so for the first time ever after
50 seasons after a hundred years of
broadcast
your life you lose it's changing the
game
we're turning it upside down baby
it's no longer you laugh you lose it's
get this
you laugh you win
no more g fuel required but it is a nice
beverage regardless ken placenta
teacher what sound does the cow make
special ed kids 322
i went
aloha there's no context to this
whatsoever
i said i don't i don't watch tyler but i
only see him
in the context of this so he just seems
like the
craziest this is great i have a great
perception of this streamer
this clip is literally everywhere i
don't know why
i mean it's impressive but this is it
is this really enough for you kids to
find a meme to repost
now the real question is is the tattoo
soundtrack copywriter or not
you ready kids
i can't hear you
that's kind of sweet that's not a really
laugh that's just wholesome
when you leave the shop but realize you
left your son
oh no ma oh no my son
this is the life you win i can laugh at
that
i don't know if i want to though i feel
uncomfortable
yeah beatboxer boy stop it i don't care
about west coast boy
we'll be closing in two minutes
[Music]
i love nsync
i don't know what that joke was
jesus christ
jacksepticeye stop killing the anime
thought please
jesus christ
what did she do
this is disrespectful as hell
thank learn to you
wow
he's the world champion in basketball
freestyle oh
god you know only real show-offs
i mean it's impressive don't get me
wrong but you know only show us really
practice this kind of stuff he's the
world champion
damn that's nasty
oh look at the dude where's
keep going jesus christ he's already
dead
i thought changing the name to you life
you win would actually benefit but
it just seems like the clips are
and i haven't even been trying all along
[Music]
oh it's a gun
oh of course it's russia jesus christ
oh my god please tell me that's water
because that is the cutest that's the
cutest thing i've ever seen in my life
so then someone throws a match
sorry i know that was a bit what is this
hit or miss
what the heck gets this huh
what is happening
oh god is he gonna get hit
oh my god
this gotta be fake
oh god oh god what the heck
if this is fake that he's doing a great
job but i really oh my god
jesus it has to be fake
that's impressive though
damn i wish myself if i saw that
hello my followers i'm here with
legendary comedian
movie star uh bill murray you know him
from such films as the ghostbusters and
the uh the ghostbusters too oh that's
right
he's doing all the best anderson films
and we're just gonna make one of my
biggest dreams come true so ready bill
yes ready ready live from new york
it says
what the hell did i just watch you laugh
your confuses so far all i got
jesus christ what is that can someone
explain why bill murray is there
and did murray just can hit that guy in
the neck
because you got some fat breasts
yeah he has some fat breasts it's your
boy reese i just got some neck all right
okay i'm cool
we're back
oh my god has that dog never seen the
car before like what
jesus christ dog please stop
stop stop
please
dog stop someone stop and dog
undefeated dog dog nobody my dog
at 5am
see what i'm talking about i'm sure he's
normal i'm sure there's nothing wrong
with
him it's just you know when people take
out of context saying i i
i don't want to judge someone's
character just by eclipse taken out of
context
but
so far it's not looking good
this is so sad this is why you drink
g-fuel
this won't happen what
what did you think was gonna happen
jesus christ like hey guys
it's me and coca-cola
[Music]
this is like put the hand over it too
like
[Music]
oh hell yeah i love me a good old yoshi
meme
oh god
[Music]
what the freak oh my god that's just
mean
that kid what can he do
flapjack do that thing you do everything
i know what this is
stop stop the tetris
stop hey it's another one of these
goddamn memes
we know it's not real we know oh
oh my god oh my god
oh wow oh my god it's amazing
it's the most beautiful thing i've ever
seen in my life
[Music]
nice very nice excellent
oh jesus christ
and he locked it as well well well done
when we go out make sure you wait like
20 seconds
[Music]
jesus hey man what's wrong lightning
mcqueen [ __ ] my mom jesus christ come
on you know better
lightning mcqueen isn't real that's true
jeff
oh gosh i'm sweating really guys i
[ __ ] your mom
that's the dumbest thing i've ever
laughed at but it's your life you win so
it doesn't matter
thank you everyone for watching you
laugh you win everyone wins today
pat yourself on the back give yourself
an extra smoothie shake
and i'll see you guys tomorrow on
another video leave a like if you laugh
and leave a like if you didn't laugh and
make sure to laugh everyone
bye
what tuber simulator is becoming
relevant
no no don't leave
no please sponsor eagle please do
something
yes
this game is still relevant god dammit